>>Mr. Manager: Good afternoon everyone, I'm
Mr. Manager.
There are certain truths in life, truths that
you should always keep a lookout for.
First of all always watch for out hop-ons,
you got to know what is and what is not a
scar dot com.
And above all you must remember there's always
money in the banana stand.
Now, philosophy is on a pretty similar quest,
it seeks to separate the difference between
illusion, the illusion of life, from what
is just a common trick.
In this vein, scholars have united philosophy
and popular culture, we are pleased to host
for the third time for the authors at Google
show a segment from that book in this case
Arrested Development and Philosophy.
Today we are joined by Tyler Shores and Kris
Phillips.
And they are speaking to us today about the
wisdom that they wrote in several chapters
from that book.
Tyler Shores is a former Googler, he later
received his graduate degree in English literature
from the University at Oxford.
He is a frequent contributor to this philosophy
and pop-culture series.
You may remember him from the 'Hero' show
and the 'Inception in Popular Culture' show.
Also, and 'The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo',
how could I forget.
Kris Phillips is an ABD graduate and a student
in philosophy at the University of Iowa.
He is a frequent editor to the series as well.
He's a metaphysics man, also contributed to
the book of 'Coffee, Grounds for Debate'.
So without further ado, we'll use the mikes
for Q&A.
So please join me as we together explore this
tiny town of big ideas this Arrested Development
and philosophy.
[Applause]
>>Kris: Thank you, thank you.
So what we're going to do today is going to
be a little bit informal.
We're going to discuss some the philosophical
issues that arise over the three very short
seasons of Arrested Development.
And we're gonna have sort of a general theme
that we think comes up in the show.
That theme being, in fact, that it may well
be worse to know things than to not know them.
[laughter]
Sort of contrary to the theme of philosophy,
philosophers are always looking for knowledge
and truth and wisdom.
We're gonna see if the Arrested Development
can maybe teach us that that's maybe not the
best way and then it looks like we're gonna
end up concluding that it is in fact not the
way you ought to live.
So we're going to look at what Arrested Development
can teach us about how we shouldn't live life.
[Chuckling]
But before we can really engage in that discussion,
we need to sort of get it clear on what exactly
is the philosophical life?
What is philosophy?
And what does it mean to engage in this sort
of life.
Well, Plato, way back in the day, said that
the unexamined life is not worth living.
But this raises, I think, two distinct questions.
The first one is a fairly important question,
that question is, what exactly is the examined
life?
And to answer that question, we need to appeal
to the mythos.
Plato discusses the mythos, he says this is
the sort of unquestioning ignorance that we
all have of the way the world actually is.
He says that throughout life we sort of grow
up and were told you're supposed to do certain
things in your lifetime.
You're supposed to get a job, you're supposed
to go to college, get married, have 2.4 kids,
live in a house with a white picket fence
and all this kind of stuff.
And that's what will make you happy.
This is what you're told.
And you're told never to question this.
You're never supposed to question it, but
we as philosophers do.
We think, you know what maybe that isn't what
makes us happy, do you even know what happiness
is?
So the second question is, why exactly would
such a life not be worth living?
Well, Socrates thought that just going through
the motions was terrible.
And he gave all sorts of reasons, there are
a bunch of dialogues and things, you can read
knows, I'm not going to bore you with all
the details of Plato here.
We have Arrested Development talk about, after
all.
So instead we are going to ask, why, well
we seek happiness of course.
But were going to ask, was Plato right? Was
Plato right that the unexamined life isn't
worth living?
And we're explore that through issues that
come up in Arrested Development, so at this
point I would like to turn it over to Tyler
for our first section
>>Tyler: Thanks, Kris .
So, I thought, considering where we are and
our audience at Google, we're all familiar
at Mountain View specifically with informal
corporate motto of "don't be evil".
So it seemed like a good place to start, of
talking about Arrested Development.
Ethics in the Bluths, there's a couple things
we should talk about here.
One of them certainly would be capitalism,
we have a couple of interesting chapters which
talk about the class system and Marxism and
what kind of representative population the
Bluths have for this kind of capitalism and
really this kind of cartoonish caricature
version of like wealthy capitalists that you
know where everything is for sale and anything
can be for sale even if it's not.
Anything can be twisted to make a buck.
So were talking about business ethics or the
lack thereof in this case.
And what happens between like, you know, one
of the things that we see in the show especially
when we're talking about George Senior. What
happens when something gets in the way of
wanting that money and you know actually getting
that money.
There are a lot of examples; we got the cornballer
of course, which is legally not for sale anywhere
including Mexico. [laughter]
The thing is dangerous if you, it'll burn
your fingerprints off.
There is, one of the other topics that we
talk about and you see throughout the show
would be commodification.
Everything is for sale, like everything has
its price.
It's one of those things that we see again
and again as you know like crass commercialism
of George Bluth, Senior, whether it's religion,
religion can be used to make a quick buck.
Exploitation has a lot to do with this too.
Whether it's selling boy fights videos, which
are extremely popular in Latin America. [laughter]
Or also under capitalism as philosophers would
want to point out, everything has its price
including people and relationships between
one person and another.
This comes up again and again.
One of the things that Marx talks about is
this, you know, the primary characteristic
of Marxian capitalism is this sort of exploitation,
this sort of like, you know, dollar amount
or this quantifying of human relations which
you know it sounds terrible, but it is something
that we engage with more often than were comfortable
to admit.
A really good example, because I think it's
funny, is Gob's suit.
This is a good example here, I think.
This was from, what episode was this from,
people know was it 'afternoon delight'?
Banana [indistinct], I think, yeah.
Anyways, like the running gag with this one
was that Gob has a suit that that you know
kind of increases in price.
Like, you know, it's first, on the first scene
there it's like he's gonna spill his coffee
but, you know, I'm not can spill coffee over
my $3000 suit, come on.
You know, not gonna help the guy who doesn't
make this much money in four months.
Not gonna take a whiz in the $5000 suit.
Anyways, the point is, yeah, this is a good
example I think of like you know putting a
dollar amount on things, like you know in
this, as Marxian proponents might say, putting
a certain capitalistic values on things.
Like you know does having more money make
someone better than another person?
We'd like to say no; but for Gob's case clearly
yes.
That's a good example, I think.
That leads to the next point, I think, which
were talking about family values it
One of the values I want to talk about is
family values.
Or yeah, Bluth family values have an interesting,
, I don't even know what she called them.
An interesting lack thereof of family values.
Annyong, of course, was only adopted by Lucille
Bluth in order to teach Buster a lesson for
not finishing his cottage cheese.
[laughter]
So, that kind of shows something, I think,
about using people.
Another thing that Marxian's like to talk
about, you know, this sort of capitalist critique
is like treating people as means to an end
instead of like ends to themselves so this
is an example, like you know you adopt a kid
in order to teach another very old man-child
a lesson.
So it's interesting to think about this actually.
The family first motto, right, we see this
in the very first episode of, you know, Arrested
Development.
You know, Michael and George Michael are having
breakfast and Michael says, "what's the most
important thing?"
"Breakfast".
George Michael is confused, he thought you
were talking about things you eat.
But family, family is the thing that you know
ostensibly one of the goals, one of the underlying
themes of Arrested Development is sort of
family first.
But family first actually means something
different when we're thinking of the Bluth
universe.
A lot of things, there's complicated examples,
like I mentioned Lucille.
A lot of Lucille's relationships are defined
in terms of power and control.
There's a lot of manipulation, a lot of lying
, a lot of, you know, playing against each
other and as Buster says, "She gets off on
withholding", and these sort of things.
So, yeah, there's that and, you know, there's
certainly, it's a very unique version of family
values and family first in this case kind
of means like, you know, yeah, family first
in the sense that this is a resource that
can be exploited for our own ends.
So there is that. Oops, excuse me.
Lastly, I guess the point to finish up this
thought is, basically the Bluths are, I remember
in one of my favorite episodes "Save Our Bluths",
Michael give this great speech, right.
He says that, you know, "Well I was really
only give this speech about how we had an
unlucky break and you know there's this great
injustice, but I'm not sure that is true.
That's not the truth, we've been given plenty
of chances and maybe the Bluths just aren't
worth saving.
Maybe were not that likable, you know, were
very self-centered."
And, I guess, that's kind of the point, like
one of the things that we talked about in
the book is that, yeah in this sense the Bluths
are putting their own, you know, individual
desires before community, before their shareholders,
before their own family members there is that.
And like these, we're talking about ethics,
and ethical decisions, but a lot of times
you know these ethical decisions seem to be
very convenient decisions for Bluth family
members.
But that leads to our next part, which is
when you talk about ethics one of the things
that's really important for philosophers and
all of us are philosophers to some extent
because we all do these things, is self-knowledge.
And self-knowledge is the next thing that
Kris is going to talk about.
>>Kris: Great, yeah and I just had one more
point to may be tack on to the end thereof
the thing.
>>Tyler: Mm hmm
>>Kris: It seems like this discussion is absolutely
perfect to illustrate the point I tried to
make it the very beginning.
In the introduction.
Seems like the Bluth family has bought wholesale
into this sort of story that were told in
America.
What makes you great is owning cool stuff.
You know Gob is maybe the best example of
that with his 3, 4, 5 and $6000 suit, come
on.
[Laughter]
So there's that.
But moving on, as Tyler was saying, one of
the really important things we need to do
is sort of get clear on who we are and who
we expect ourselves to be.
And that's actually a surprisingly complicated
question.
Which I think the Bluth characters in particular
Gob and Tobias Fünke maybe illustrate just
how difficult this can be.
So, we were talking about self-knowledge.
We need to sort of get it clear on what the
self is first.
And there, this raises a number of different
issues, I think there are four or maybe five
interconnected issues when we're talking about
the self and how we define it.
So there are these different questions of
self-identity.
And the first one is going to be what I'm
calling the metaphysical question.
What makes somebody who they are as opposed
to somebody else?
So here for example we have the Richter quintuplets,
we have Andy who is the showoff, we have Donnie
who is the smart one, Chareth on the end over
there is the flirt.
>>Tyler:Rocky is the tough one.
>>Kris: Rocky is the tough one, and the stunt
doubles.
And we can show Emmitt's face presumably because
he is shy or something.
But in any case, they all look the same, they're
all, I'll give it away here, played by the
same actor, sorry to break that to you. [laughter]
And so we might wonder what exactly is it
that makes them different from one another?
Why are they different people? How are they
different people?
And what is doing the work of making them
We see this throughout the entire show.
We see it with Anne who's played by two different
actresses.
We see it with George Senior and Oscar, two
different characters played by the same person.
And a lot sort of hinges on mistaken identity
throughout the show especially if you're watching
closely with George and Oscar.
And so one answer to the metaphysical question
is to sort of deal with essences.
Essential character traits and things like
this, but that can kind of get us into trouble
depending on how we go about trying to respond
to that.
So that's one issue.
The next issue as an epistemological issue.
Epistemology is the philosophical view that,
or the area philosophy where were concerned
with knowledge, how we attain knowledge, what
the nature of knowledge is, what's the nature
of justification and evidence.
And so there are these questions, how exactly
do we know who we are, either in a social
sense or in a sort of this deeper or broader
metaphysical sense, I shouldn't say deeper.
And so this actually gives rise to first and
third person questions.
The first person question is how do I know
who I am, how do I know that I'm the same
person I used to be?
And the third person question is the one that
we see played out with the cops constantly
throughout the show.
How do we know that this is in fact not Oscar?
And we have George Senior as we've been trying
to get him for so long.
So these are sort of important relevant questions
as well.
And then we also have this persistence question.
How do I know that I'm the same person from
one moment to the next?
What connects me to my past and future selves?
If I'm concerned with living the good life,
I'm concerned with living a good life not
just right this minute but probably also into
the future and continuing to do the right
thing.
So what connects me to that person and this
is sort of, this is tied closely with the
metaphysical issues as well.
Then there's one last question that's important
and we have an entire chapter on this very
last question of personal identity.
And it's the social issue.
In what way is society sort of defining who
we are and how much power do we let them have
or is it that were letting them have it at
all in the first place?
It's not really clear.
All of these things are absolutely important,
and they're critical to sort of get a clear
idea of how you might want to respond to it
or what exactly it is that's doing this before
we can even try make sense of how we can be
happy or know ourselves.
So this is sort of background information.
I mentioned Ann a moment ago by way of the
metaphysical question.
She's a particularly nice [laughter] particularly
nice example of someone who has essential
characteristics and all we're given in the
show is a basic description of Ann.
That she's bland, that she is sort of ambiguously
Christian somehow, she lives on Bethlehem
time, engages in hours of silent prayer and
we know that.
>>Tyler: She does this really adorable thing
with an egg where she puts in an egg in her
mouth and squirts a packet of mayonnaise and
mmmm.
>>Kris: I think she calls it a mayonegg.
[laughter]
>>Tyler: It is a mayonegg
>>Kris: But as a result, we find that she
in fact gets sort of lumped in with this.
And I bet, I've given talks about this before
in the fact most people haven't even recognize
that she was played by two different actresses,
that's how bland she is.
[Laughter]
Avid fans of the show don't even recognize
this.
And so people end up sort of, they call her
different names, they call her Bland, they
call her Ann.
They say it's as Ann on the nose on plain's
face.
And so you might not think that this is doing
the metaphysical work of making her who she
is, but it does seem like, as far as the character
goes, that does play a very important role.
And so that's one example of the metaphysical
issues, or a response to them. [laughter]
What do we do with Tobias.
Tobias stands in a peculiar relationship to
himself.
We'll put it that way.
He claims to have just well he says he just
blew himself.
That's a strange relationship as far as I
can tell.
>>Tyler:
Isn't it amazing what you can find on Google?
[laughter]
That's not an actual ice cream flavor, sorry.
But it looks really cool
>>Kris: So what can
>>Tyler: [whispers] lets switch places
>>Kris: Yeah, let's switch places.
So what can Gob teach us, or I'm sorry ,Tobias
teach us about sort of self-awareness, or
self-knowledge?Well, he believes all sorts
of things about himself.
He believes that he is an outstanding actor.
This is obviously false.
He also believes that he is an accomplished
analrapist.
[laughter]
And it's okay it's pronounced analrapist,
not the way you might be thinking.
>>Tyler: Important for people on Google to,
I mean
>>Kris:Yes
>>Tyler: I mean YouTube know that
>>Kris:Don't go googling analrapist.
It's supposed to be a combination of analyst
and therapist, a professional twice over.
But unfortunately really the business cards
got him in trouble for that one.
And so everybody else sort of recognizes that
Tobias is this total disaster, but he's living
in this fantasy world.
And insofar as he is living in this fantasy
world, he doesn't seem to be living a very
good life.
He's convinced himself that he's this great
actor; he even misses out on subtle social
clues during a job interview, during the tryout
for the commercial for the fire sale.
He thinks it's actually a fire, and so he
acts in a manner that, I guess, only Tobias
would fire, but anyway you get the idea.
He's rolling around on the ground singing
Amazing Grace.
[laughter]
This sort of demonstrates a ridiculous amount
of, I guess, a ridiculous lack of self-knowledge.
So it seems like this is one of the ways that
you don't want to try and structure your life
if you're trying to live the good life.
His sexual identity is unclear to everyone.
Probably also himself, we have an article
specifically about how he identifies with
both genders in various situations and he
acts out both male and female character traits.
And obviously then there's the double entendres
and issues that we will return to momentarily.
But these sort of things seem like they're
the kind of things that you need to have a
grip on before you can really be happy.
>>Tyler: One of my favorite Tobias quotes,
just to interject is from the Family Ties
episode, where the long-lost Bluth sister
apparently comes and Tobias has this great
quote where they're talking about, 'oh the
sibling, is it a he, is it a she'?
He she what's the difference.
And Tobias says, "Oh here, here, in the dark
it all looks the same."
[laughter]
That's a good one, that kind of, that's it
in a nutshell actually.
>>Kris: That's right.
And so we have a really nice quote from one
of our contributors here. We're perplexed
by Tobias in general and his sexual orientation
in particular.
Tobias possesses and acts upon both feminine
and masculine traits.
In the case of Tobias we can say he's an enigma
because he has an ambiguous gender.
It's just a little teaser for the book that
you should all read immediately.
What about Gob?
Gob is deluded in any number of ways as well,
obviously he's also convinced that he's an
outstanding Magician even though he continuously
gives away the secrets to all of the tricks
that he vowed to protect forever by creating
the magicians alliance.
He constantly and intentionally loses memories.
He carries around what he calls 'forget me
nows' but we of course all know them as roofies.
[laughter]
Because he wants to protect, he thinks, himself
and others from giving away the secrets of
his craft.
But he ends up, it seems, taking them more
often than giving them.
He'll witnessed things that he doesn't really
want to see, for example, for example his
parents being intimate in a conjugal trailer.
And he will then wipe out his own memory.
Well, there's this philosopher, 17th century
philosopher, English guy John Locke, very
important guy.
And he maintained that when we're talking
about identity over time, you actually have
to have a direct memory connection to a previous
self in order to be the same person.
Without it, were talking different people.
Now I don't mean different bodies, and I don't
mean anything like that, but he thinks, Locke
things that there can be different persons
understood in a morally relevant sense that
exist within one body.
And with Gob, it seems like there are hundreds
of people inhabiting his body over the course
of his lifetime.
Precisely because he keeps trying to forget
things.
Because he finds them disturbing, or otherwise.
And so when you remind him, or when we don't
remind him, when Michael reminds him of the
terrible things that he seen that are terrible,
he freaks out and engages in this discussion
of the first person.
He says, "I've done no such thing, That was
not me, I could, what is wrong with you where
you getting this and why are you trying to
make me think about that, I have a sense of
propriety, Michael."
>>Tyler:That's an interesting question though,
you know, like that is not me, okay then who
was that, what Gob was that?
>>Kris: Exactly
>>Tyler:The forgotten Gob, the one without
memories?
>>Kris: Right
>>Tyler: Interesting questions about memory,
and like that's one of my favorite topics
and one of my favorite movies was Eternal
Sunshine of the Spotless Mind, if you haven't
seen it's excellent.
With Jim Carrey and Kate Winslet? Right?
Okay, anyways, that question of continuity
of the memory and if you start forgetting
memories which constitute your core self,
like who are you?
And if you're not that person that you were
5 minutes Ago, then who is that person that
it's gonna be 5 minutes from now?
Anyways.
>>Kris: Exactly.
But Gob illustrates self-knowledge and other
ways that, that are helpful.
We have this excellent chapter on Sartrian
bad faith.
Sartre has this sense of what makes us different
from other beings is that we have a radical
freedom to do whatever it is that we set ourselves
to do.
And we don't allow social roles or factors
to define who we are and what we are.
And so living in good faith is an exercise
of that radical freedom.
To not sort of fall into that sort of social
roles and let them define you or your actions
or things like this.
And so he has this example, Sartre does, of
a waiter.
And he says of the waiter that his movement
is too quick and too forward, little too precise,
little too rapid.
He comes towards the patrons with a step little
too quick, he bends forward a little too eagerly,
his voice, his eyes express an interest a
little too solicitous for the order of the
customer.
Well, this sounds an awful lot like Gob right
before the Save Our Bluths benefit.
Gob takes on the role of a waiter, for a little
bit.
Because he thinks it's hilarious.
>>Tyler:With club sauce
>>Kris: Right with club sauce.
He does this because Gob is exercising this
sort of ironic notion that he would ever work
for a living.
This is not the kind a role that he would
ever enter into.
He's not subservient to anyone.
And so he is, has this moment of radical self-awareness
when he's pretending to serve food to his
mother at the, at the [pause]
>>Tyler:The country club, I forget the name
of it
>>Kris: The country club, right, while they're
pitching to try and get people to donate money
to save the Bluths.
And so even though he's acting ironically,
he's acting in good faith because he's not
letting this role that he's taking on define
him and define who he is and what he is, in
fact, he's making fun of the role itself and
performing it.
And so it continues on, and he does this,
and so ultimately as is what often happens,
Gob ends up falling into the role and letting
the role sort of take over for him.
Yes?
>>male#1: [indistinct]
Wasn't he being subservient to his mother?
>>Kris: Yes, he's always subservient to his
mother, that's for sure.
That's a fair point.
But not to the role itself, not to the role
of being a waiter.
This is, he thinks, hilarious.
And ironic.
But he does end up buying into it, and in
fact gets very upset when at the save our
Bluths benefit, people start leaving because
the food was inedible and he realized he wasn't
ever make the money that he was supposed to
make as a server.
And he let the role sort of take over for
him, or take him over.
And so of course we have him and perhaps the
best role that he ever is, as a magician.
And so that's, that's where I'm going to leave
off here on the identity issue.
There's a lot of, sort of, rich philosophical
issues that happen here.
There's a lot to continue talking about, but
we have more.
>>Tyler: Mmm Hmm
Yeah, that's a good question you, thanks for
the question about like different roles, it's
something were gonna be talking about hopefully
chat about with you guys even more with question
and answers.
But to continue, to move onwards, our third
point in how not to live the philosophical
life according to Arrested Development, is
say exactly what you mean.
I'm a word nerd, so I love the wordplay and
then the use and abuse of language in Arrested
Development.
I think that to me, personally, like my personal
theory is it's one of those things that makes
the show just so funny is the fact that there
is this kind of twisting and playfulness with
language for sure.
We got an example of the literal Doctor, I'll
get to that in the second.
We have an excellent chapter on that where
we talk about language in the book.
And there's a good example if you remember
from the wedding when George Michael and Maeby
get pretend married.
But then they actually get married even though
they thought it was a fake wedding so that's
a good example because it says a lot about
language.
One of the things that I'm interested in is
it something that J L Austin this philosopher
of language called performative speech.
And performative a speech is basically not
just language that describes something, like
I am standing here. Performative speech is
more like something that does something that
is actually, it's performing the action that
it's talking about.
That happens when you say 'I pronounce you
man and wife'.
It happens when you're saying something like
'I promise, I swear, I bet'.
These are all kind of examples of performative
speech.
There is something, if we have time at the
end I'd like to talk about is, just like what
language is.
Like what effects does language have, you
know like what makes something real like I
don't know Kris maybe you have, it's a big
question.
>>Kris: It's a huge question
>>Tyler: You know like for example like to
part to use a wedding example even more, so
like I'm an ordained minister according to
my like thing that I got from the Internet.
And that's a fair question I think about you
know like what is real, what makes something
actually real, like how do we understand these
rules.
The point is, I guess, if I'm trying to make
is that language sometimes has a very real
effect in the world.
Specifically for us, what we're interested
in is that language has humorous effects.
Context is absolutely everything.
When we're talking about you know like how
a joke happens, like you know obviously it
needs at least two parties, the speaker and
the hearer.
But it also like, you know, we have to incorporate
a lot of things that were talking about, the
humorous effects of language; it's a context,
it's the role the speaker, the role of the
audience.
The historical period, and kind of the cultural
you know milieu that the speaker and the audience
inhabit.
So in order to, like you know, we have to
be at a certain place in a certain time in
order to, like, understand certain jokes.
And I think Arrested Development does that
extremely well.
Like here's one my favorite examples right,
the literal Doctor.
So when Tobias is hit by car,
[laughter[
He was also blue at the time so like no one
could see him in the dark.
When Lindsay says, "how's my husband?" literal
Doctor says, "it looks like he's dead", which
everyone is horrified to read about or hear
about.
And then Michael is like this isn't the first
encounter with the literal Doctor. So at this
point Michael says, "Wait, you looks like
he's dead or he is dead?"
And literal Doctor says, "It looks like he's
dead, he's covered in blue paint or something."
And you know like so literally speaking, like
when you're reading on a paper like yeah,
it's not entirely unreasonable to understand
what the literal Doctor was trying to say,
but that's why it's funny is the fact that
you know they play with language in this sort
of way.
And there's tons of examples like this of
you know one person saying one thing and actually
taking that unintended meaning to mean something
else.
This is probably my second favorite related
Gob Bluth clip.
This was when Gob was apparently married for
a little while to his Amy Fuller is that her
name?
>>Kris: Yes
>>Tyler: His real-life wife played this role
of Gob's wife in this episode.
[Pause]
I really have to read this, like I wish we
could do, we could even do a staged reading
of this.
I'll just --
>>Kris: Do you want to, I'd be happy to--
>>Tyler: Yes, lets actually.
>>Kris: Oh this will be fantastic, I'm excited.
>>Tyler: I'll play Gob's wife
>>Kris: OK
>>Tyler: So like, just to give this little
more context, like, I'm saying, so much of
the, what's funny about Arrested Development
has to do with what the hearer interprets
or misinterprets.
And in this case Gob and Gob's wife are playing
the role of speaker and hearer in this case.
So when Gob's wife says, "I'm in love with
your Brother in Law"
>>Kris: You're in love with your own brother,
the one in the army
>>Tyler: No, I'm in love with your sister's
husband.
>>Kris: Michael?
Michael.
>>Tyler: No, that's your sister's brother
>>Kris: No, I'm my sister's brother, me, you're
in love with me.
>>Tyler: No, I'm in love with Tobias
>>Kris: My Brother in Law?
[Laughter]
>>Tyler: So anyways we have this really good,
one of our contributors really broke down
this section and literally speaking if you
take it from word to word, there are ways
in which this isn't entirely inaccurate.
You could if you were Gob or someone like
Gob read it this way.
But most people don't, like again, context
has a lot to do with it.
Like it should've been clear, based on the
roles involved that this is a fairly straightforward,
non-confusing conversation.
But it's really funny this way.
And again like the point I'm trying to make
is that words are never uttered in a vacuum
right?
So meaning is never understood outside of
the context of where does this thing happen,
so in this case it's the context of speaker
and hearer, and the context of our dramatic
reading here which is sort of like the context
of husband, wife and very confused husband
who also has brothers and has brothers in
law and these sort of things.
So a perfect use of humor through language
in Arrested Development.
One of the things that I like to kind of elaborate
on the theory I have that language is one
of the things that makes Arrested Development
so funny for us is the use of abusive language.
Because it reveals interesting things about
how normal language works like the fact of
how a particular utterance, what it means
in these sort of things.
But basically when Arrested Development plays
with language in this sort of way, it takes
it out of its normal everyday use and it actually
makes us pay attention if you go back and
re-watch episodes or right philosophy chapters
on these sort of things.
It makes you think about how normal language
works by seeing how normal language doesn't
work.
So I think that's one of the values of the
show.
Whoops, didn't see that one for a second.
[Laughter]
I guess, here's another, I'll read this one,
we don't have to do a dramatic reading of
this one but this is a Tobias quote that I
rather liked.
I don't remember what episode, maybe someone
out there will know.
But, he's talking to Lucille, and he says,
"You know, Mother Lucille, there's a psychological
concept known as denial, that I believe you're
evincing. It's when a thought is so hateful
that the mind literally rejects it."
Lucille Lynch says, "You are a worse psychiatrist
than you are a son-in-law, and you will never
get work as an actor because you have no talent."
And Tobias says "Well, if she's not going
to say anything, I certainly can't help her."
[Laughter]
So it's a good example of communication, communication
takes two roles it needs a speaker and the
hearer in this case we have like what ostensibly
should've been a successful communication
act, one person saying something another person
saying something but in this case it doesn't
work if the hearer is just Tobias and completely
oblivious.
But I've thought about this because we are
here at authors I've Google and I've been
on both ends of these talks a lot and it kind
of made me think about what is it a speaker
does?
Like what is communication?
And a lot of it has to do with not so much
what a speaker says so much because a lot
of these things, were not presenting so many
new ideas, as we are were taking ideas that
a lot of us are already familiar with and
saying them in a different way.
I think that that's a lot of what communication
is, and maybe even like a fair description
of philosophy sometimes, you know like saying
things in totally different way I guess to
think about these things.
So anyways.
The last quote I wanted to read is, do we
have the Freud one up here, no.
There's a Freud quote about, Freud's definition
of a joke like what a joke is. I actually
think it's a good one.
Freud says and I quote, "The pleasure of a
joke lies in a kind of economy, at all times
we are expending energy and monitoring our
subconscious so as to ensure that our conscious
perceptions come through a filtering control.
The joke because it breaks down the control
gives the monitoring system a holiday."
So that's a very long-winded way of saying
that is what we like about and enjoy about
humor and sitcoms in these sort of things
is it gives us a break.
It's that belief of how the world normally
should be, even if for a second a split second
I like to laugh and joke, that is one of the
things that we enjoy, the pleasure of comedy.
So moving on to point number four which Kris
is going to talk about.
>>Kris: Absolutely.
So the fourth way that you're not supposed
to live is to ignore the value of experience,
previous experiences for knowledge.
And I think this is a jarring shift from technical
discussion of language to knowledge generally.
But knowledge is, I think, naturally imparted
through language.
That's how we sort of, that's what we're doing
right now.
When it's written, when it's spoken there's
all sorts of ways that you can muck things
up.
And of course, another way that you can sort
of ruin things is by ignoring your past.
We mentioned this before with Gob and the
roofies he keeps taking.
There are other times where he takes them
that we'll see strategically so that he doesn't
have to learn from his mistakes.
The huge mistakes that he keeps making.
[Laughter]
Sorry, this one cracks me up.
So we value the role of experience generally
in knowledge.
We want to, we always say you should learn
from your past through seeking knowledge or
seeking self-knowledge, self-awareness from
the world around us; we take knowledge to
be something that's valuable.
But what exactly is knowledge?
This is something with them and discuss a
little bit here we have a couple chapters
on this.
And experience plays a fairly important role,
but exactly how do we cash out experience,
what role does it play?
One of the issues is that the Bluth's tend
to ignore all past experiences.
Gob especially as I mentioned continually
makes huge mistakes and he continually makes
the same huge mistake over and over and over
again.
It's almost always based on some lame character
trait.
But Buster here can help us illustrate another
point about knowledge.
About how tricky knowledge can actually be.
So there's this classic problem, and it takes
an academic to come up with something like
this.
And Buster is something of an academic; he
certainly had plenty of graduate school, as
have I.
I hope that what I'm doing is a little bit
more practical than 18th century agrarian
business theory, or cartography.
But you know, then again, I do philosophy
and so to my parents it's all the same.
So in any case, he's an academic, he seems
to know all sorts of things but does he really
know much of anything?
And does he know anything that actually matters?
We see here he's a little bit frightened by
Oscar, maybe with good reason.
And we also have found out through some sort
of interesting experiences that Oscar is,
in fact, Buster's real father.
But does Buster know that?
The way in which he comes to know it seems
to be sort of problematic.
He hits all the sort of classic requirements
for knowledge.
Buster, in fact, believes that Oscar is his
father, he has good reason to believe it in
fact a guy who looks just like his uncle came
to him in the middle of the night and said
I'm not your uncle, I'm your father.
And it turns out that it's, in fact, true
that Oscar is his father, but what's crazy
about this and what seems to make it a problem
is that the man who said I'm not your uncle,
I'm your father was George Senior in a wig.
[pause]
Right so he has evidence for this true belief,
but it seems like the evidence is bad evidence.
Because if he had gotten clear about who was
telling him that it was his father he would've
never come across this what's actually true
belief.
So does he really know?
I'm not sure, there's all kinds of philosophers
who are really concerned with this, primarily
epistemologists.
I have a chapter on that with one of my friends.
But so what, maybe Buster doesn't know in
this sort of ridiculous, convoluted, philosophical
sense, all that matters is that he was able
to confront Lucille and then she confirmed
it and that's good enough.
We're off and running.
But consider Wayne Jarvis.
This is the replacement for Barry Zuckerkorn
who then turned around and started prosecuting
the Bluth family.
So he seemed to know a bunch of things too.
And he certainly thought he knew what he was
seeing, right?
So we're talking about experience and how
experience plays an important role in knowledge.
And we take visual experience, or the senses
to be a pretty good indicator that we are
learning something.
But Wayne Jarvis was looking at a photograph
that he got off the Bluth company server.
Does anybody remember what the photograph
was?
Or what he thought it was?
I won't make you say anything crude.
>>female #1: Iraqi landscape
>>Kris: They thought it was Iraqi landscape.
Because George was being charged with having
built houses on, in Iraq.
So what he thought was that he saw a picture
of Iraqi landscape which was where they were
building houses to hide weapons of mass distraction.
And he saw this precisely because, you might
say, he's a prosecutor, he's looking for incriminating
evidence so when he comes across a photograph
that might look like landscape, he's gonna
to see it exactly as that.
And this is an issue in philosophy and the
philosophy of science in particular, but in
epistemology and generally called the theory
ladeness of observation.
That is, we see certain things, not just sort
of for what they are but we interpret them
and our sort of background theories are informing
the way that we experience the world.
All the time.
And so part of the problem is that, as we
saw in the first slide, Barry was able to
point out that what it was in fact not an
Iraqi landscape but was Tobias's balls.
[Laughter]
So I'm not going to subject you to the actual
photo, were not gonna do that.
But unlike, so Wayne Jarvis is unlike Gob
in that he probably learned from this.
He probably got a little bit embarrassed;
almost started a war on the basis of this.
So it's pretty bad evidence, pretty flimsy.
But the Bluths show us what not to do.
Jarvis sort of points us at something that
we need to be aware of in order to not make
the same huge mistake.
But Gob on the other hand here, you want to
do another reenactment?
>>Tyler: Yes.
>>Kris: OK.
>>Tyler:
I call Steve Holt.
[Laughter]
>>Kris: Steve Holt, OK
>>Tyler: "I've made a huge mistake"
>>Kris: "I know the feeling; I had you. I'm
your father, Steve Holt, I can't hide from
it anymore."
>>Tyler: "I won't forget this, Dad."
>>Kris: "I will" and then he pops a roofie,
drinks it and then in a tender moments says
"I will" crying a little bit.
So again, we have this situation where Gob
is sort of forced to be aware of his own mistakes.
He's self-aware and forced to be, and confronted
with it in the most impassioned way possible.
And yet he decides, nope, I'm out; I don't
want this, I don't want to learn from it,
I don't want real-life experiences, going
back to the previous discussion, somebody
else can have it.
>>Tyler:
Wrapping things up this brings us to point
number five about how not to live, or how
to live a philosophical life according to
Arrested Development.
This one would be about telling good stories,
and I think narrative is like you know, the
story structure of Arrested Development is
very unique.
And it's certainly one of the things that
I'm most interested in.
This was the chapter that I wrote, you should
check it out it's awesome.
But there's a lot to say about Arrested Development
as a, as an actual sitcom.
In a lot of ways I think you could even understand
Arrested Development as a show about television.
Think about it as this pseudodocumentary with
a voice-over narrative, constant cut forwards
and flashbacks and these sort of things.
So it kind of place with the conventions of
like what a documentary is and what can or
can't be done on television.
Let me take a step back and talk about, in
the chapter I talk about, in the poetics Aristotle
a Greek philosopher from 380 BC, talks about
what a story is.
A story is a thing that it has to have a beginning,
middle and an ending.
Like it has to have some sort of structure,
it has to have or provide us as story receivers
or readers with some sort of sense of like
how things are going to get from one place
to another.
We create stories because we want to explain
why things are the way they are, how they
relate and how they began and how they end.
Otherwise we're left was something like a
Samuel Beckett play where's just sort of a
lot of nothingness.
But if you think about what television is,
specifically like the narration in Arrested
Development, I think it helps us, you know,
not unlike what I was talking about before
with language, how it plays with language.
It helps us kind of think about the ways that
we, how we relate to stories the way we do,
why we find meaning in the world through stories.
We really do like narrative, we really do
like stories. There's a certain pleasure that
we get from how we make sense of events in
a lot of ways a lot of philosophers think
that narrative, thinking in terms of narrative
is actually at the root of human thought.
We tend to like a lot of things we do, whether
it's gossiping, telling stories or dreaming
or whatever.
These all have some sort of structure with
it, someone doing something's going somewhere
or some variation of that.
So narrative is kind of like, it certainly
is an important means for us to find how we
learn about the world and how we learn about
ourselves, I think.
I mean think about when you're a kid for a
second, all right.
So like think about the kind of delight that
you get when you reach the end of the story,
reach like the end.
Where that delight comes from is kind of like
something that I write about in this chapter
and it gives us hope basically that there's
an underlying structure to things.
That in real life things don't happen that
way, there is no beginning, middle, and end.
Like things don't usually happen on time,
or there's not usually like to clear tidy
sense of resolution.
That's how life is, so narrative is our way
of kind of imposing meaning on things.
When we tell the stories about things, we
like the things to make sense, we like them
to lead from one thing to another.
Narrative asks us not only questions of why,
but what.
There's an example and I'm gonna skip this
one, we'll come back to it, I promise.
In the chapter I talk about how stories can
be used.
Stories can be used for pretty much anything,
just like statistics or you know, many other
types of things like the bad news, the good
news is that we can use stories for whatever
purposes we want, the bad news is that we
can use stories for whatever purposes that
we want.
In this case there's the J Walter weatherman,
the one armed man.
This was certainly one of my favorite things
when, you know like the point of these were
like, George Senior was trying to teach the
kids a lesson.
That's why you don't leave a note, that's
why you don't yell.
And like you know he's always doing this and
when Michael says, 'I want the guy with the
fake arm and the fake blood, I want Walter
Weatherman, how do I get a hold of him'.
And then George Senior says like, 'yeah he's
dead, you killed him when you left the door
open on the air-conditioner'.
[Laughter]
So it's kind of, this is a good example I
think of sort of like appropriating stories
for a lot of different meanings, like George
Senior does this easily like slipping without
even a second thought.
So that's kind of a good example, I think,
of what this does.
Like this is a way that we sort of twist stories
to fit our own means.
Anyways one of the most important characters
I want to talk about as we're sort of wrapping
things up, and then we'll get to everyone's
questions is the narrator, of course. Ron
Howard is the narrator, who is one of my favorite
characters and I think he has some of the
best lines in the show.
Narration storytelling basically entails a
certain act of interpretation.
There's always some sort of interpreting,
some sort of moral choice about meaning.
What you include in the story and what you
leave out and what that says about you for
telling stories about yourself.
And again this kind of like, this narrative
convention in Arrested Development kind of
gives us a luxury we don't normally have.
My favorite example, and it seemed apropos
for today's talk is when Lindsay is, Maeby's
of shooting a movie somewhere, and Lindsay
guesses that Maeby is in Sacramindy for her
debate club semi-finals.
And the narrator very quickly jumps in and
says, "There is no, she was not in, there
was no debate club and a quick Google search
of the word Sacramindy him up with zero results
and the following helpful question did you
mean Sacramento?"
So it's a quick like one second thing, but
the idea behind that is that there's this
built-in narrative safety net of like we don't
always, like I said, when we talk about narrative
interpretation we don't always get things
right.
The Bluths rarely get things right, and that's
where the narrative, the narrator's role comes
in to kind of put things you know in the right
place.
And I guess the kind of wrap up my thoughts
on this, I want to leave you with, a quote
from Friedrich Nietzsche where he says basically,
and this is a good model not only for understanding
Arrested Development, but something for us
to just think about.
Nietzsche wants us to be more like the artist
who can kind of see an object as sort of you
know attention pay attention to both but the
big and small details.
So basically what Nietzsche is saying is that
an artist has the capability of framing things
in a certain way so you're looking at only
certain parts.
The analogy that were trying to use here is
that that's basically what we do not only
in watching Arrested Development, but kind
of what we're doing when we're talking about
all the things within our life.
Like were picking selective moments; we're
picture framing things, and putting things
in a certain context.
So Nietzsche says we need to be more like
poets and you know, realize were making kind
of art out of our own lives.
And you have any closing thoughts to add before
the wrap things up?
>>Kris: I was going to say I guess just as
with any good story, were going to have to
call it a day here and leave you hopefully
wanting more.
The book, of course, is an attempt to sort
of introduce you too ways to avoid making
huge mistakes.
And I hope that we've been able to point out
some of the ways that you in fact ought not
to live according to the Bluths.
So thank you for being here and thank you
for listening.
[Applause]
>> Mr. Manager: So do we have questions that
the mike and at these roving microphones.>>male
#2:
If you could pick a favorite episode Kris
which episode would you pick?
>>Kris: [Sigh]
[Pause]
It might be peer pressure.
>>Tyler: Okay. Pressure is good.
>>Kris: I think peer pressure might be.
>>Tyler: I go with SOBs, that's very meta-humor
is of course where they're making all the
jokes about Arrested Development getting canceled
and you know like 'yes save our show' and
the homebuyers, homebuyers what does the O
stand for?
>>Kris: Home builder's Organization
>>Tyler: Yeah, they don't want us
>>Kris: That's right.
>>Tyler: So it's showtime for us.
>>Kris: So it's showtime, yeah.
>>Tyler: Yeah.
>>Kris: If you showtime, let's put on a show.
>>male #3: So how would you comment on the
use and the metaphor of the OC and like the
culture of life down there throughout the
show?
>>Tyler: That's an interesting question.
I mean there's certainly kind of like a fantasyland
aspect to it.
It kind of reminds me of like the Simpsons
in a lot of ways where like Springfield, where
is Springfield?
You know like everywhere and nowhere.
The OC is kind of like that to where they
have like, and they conveniently have a little
England, Little Britain, there is no little
Britain in the OC.
Right?
I mean, I googled it once, there's not.
[Laughter]
But you know like they kind of have these
things to kind of suit the conventions and
the conveniences of the show.
So there's something about that.
I don't know, it's a good question because
you know I don't really know what to think
about the, and what's with the whole don't
call it that thing.
Like is it just.
>>Kris: It's just a reference to the TV show,
I think.
>>Tyler: Yeah, OK.
>>Kris: No, I was gonna say also just added
adding on, we do have a chapter in the book
on the sort of upscale culture or trying to
fake it into the upscale culture.
And so I think a part of that is both a send-up
of this sort of American dream, and then also
maybe a critique of putting yourself into
really awful situations in order to fulfill
this dream that's itself kind of a joke.
And that's another one of the chapters, that's
worth considering.
And so I think that that's one of the same
issues is going on there.
>>female#2: Great presentation thank you.
<Kris and Tyler>
Thank you
>>female #2:
I wanted to ask what was, what has been the
perception of a work like this within the
broader field of film studies and philosophy?
And in kind of the academic community?
>>Kris: By and large philosophers, I think,
are a fickle bunch.
And so I think that there's sort of a mixed
reception in the philosophical community about
the way these kinds of works are received.
I think that the right way to view them is
introducing core philosophical issues to a
broader audience.
Trying to take ourselves out of, so to speak,
the ivory tower and break it right down next
to the banana stand on the boardwalk in the
OC and sort of spread the word.
I couldn't think to the film community, I'm
not really sure.
I do have a cool anecdote though, I met David
Cross last week in Iowa.
Weird right?
I met David Cross in a bar, and I presented
him a copy of the book and he was so excited
he actually started reading it out loud to
other members, or other people who were at
the bar.
So that was pretty much the highlight of my
life.
[Laughter]
Forget the degrees, you know those don't matter
compared to this.
>>male #4: And what about the idea of narrator
as character and as omniscient in person and
as Ron Howard.
>>Tyler: Well I mean that's a good question
two, because I mean the narrator is certainly
in a unique position in the show where you
remember the one where Kitty is at the bar
and she's threatening Michael and she says
like, "Did you hear that everyone Michael
Bluth is threatening me."
And then she, you know, like she flashes everyone
and John Beard who is actually a Los Angeles
Fox News anchor, he was in that, and he was
like you know I got a get out of here I can't
be part of the script; I can't be part of
the story, I can't be seen.
And then he's on the news later with this
thing that says eyewitness which is clever
because it says 'I' instead of eyewitness,
and he's saying like you know a local woman
bares all at local, at a bar, news at 11,
sources say.
The source he's talking about is himself.
So that kind of like, the John Beard appearance
was sort of like a, sort of like a surrogate
for the narrator character.
I mean, the problem with the narrator like
that is that they are both character, they're
both narrator and participant sometimes.
And that's basically I guess one of things
I talk about in my book is that were always
in that role.
Like when we're telling, were always telling
stories about ourselves, we are both our narrators
and main characters.
So that's hard, like how do you separate yourself
from being the person telling the story but
also the one telling the story about yourself.
So those are the kind of questions I'm always
interested in, and I think it's, you know,
well worth thinking about.
Because these are things that we engage with
every day, whether we realize it or not.
Manager: Alright well, Tyler and Kris , thank
you for stopping by and speaking with us for
authors at Google.
[Applause]
>>Kris and Tyler: Thanks